if you have just started Metal Gear
Solid 5 the phantom pain you're still
fairly early into the game there's an
unlockable feature that you probably
want to rush towards it's the gunsmith
weapon customization and I wish I knew
about it earlier so seriously consider
putting down those side quests and
unlock the gunsmith ASAP without
spoiling too much to unlock this feature
you'll need to complete mission 13
pitch-dark and then completing the three
legendary gunsmith side-ops
107 to 109 finish these and you my
friend are ready to lose hours to gun
sniffing at this point in time I hope
you saved some GMP because if you
haven't bought many weapon upgrades
already you're going to have a tough
time using the gunsmiths full potential
the key here is to purchase upgrades in
one type of weapon category ie the more
assault rifle upgrades you buy the more
custom options you have for that weapon
class so ideally conserve GMP to unlock
weapon upgrades for classes you wish to
gunsmith and those are your early stages
to gunsmith and right there try your
best to focus on two or more weapon
classes here I focused on sniper and
assault rifle and created two iterations
of each short and long ranged here we
have an M RS for base with an S barrel
for high firing speed and extended
banana mag clip now pair this puppy up
with the long ranged m 2000 d sniper
rifle base and it ran off
HP barrel for that extra long range and
then a 2 to a x scope oh now we're
talking but here's another scenario say
you want to carry a rocket launcher or
tranq sniper in that second primary slot
but still want to retain long-distance
sniping meat both ways by customizing a
longer ranged assault class rifle start
off with the longer range un arc base
attach of bamboo Toph barrel for some
additional range and then tech on a 2 x
booster optic with a red dot closing the
gap between range and close encounters
those are just two examples of loadouts
you can customize and that's only at 24%
game completion meaning down the road
you're going to find yourself
continually shaping and customizing your
weapon layouts if you have any hot
combos of your own put them in the
comment section below thanks for
watching and be
careful down there soldier